I never have been to therapy that's what
I was going to talk about with you you
never went to therapy but the show but I
had all my therapy on the show in front
of everybody and you know when I first
started in
1986 with the national show nobody was
going to therapy even speaking about
therapy on television was like taboo
taboo nobody nobody even and now
everybody has gone to therapy so I did
my therapy in front of exposed to
everyone at a time when people were
still just adjusting their own
Consciousness to the idea of accepting
somebody else being able to counsel you
about your life I just I always love
help them see things differently that
you know coming on on your meeting you
for the first time when I was 14 and
it's funny cuz I'm happy to tell you now
that I don't think and feel any of those
things about
myself